hello everybody welcome to this one
tablet session where I'll be playing to
people
my name is a big wanker I'm here with
Kayla Josephine what's up man are you
let's see let's see
so you guys can challenge me in chess 24
my nick name is jose cuenca and i see
that everybody's joining already the
chat I can see that kata treatment
Shandy you can challenge me 3 minute
game so 5-minute games should be fine I
see I have a lot of challenges already
so we are ready to to go and you can
answer you can ask me any questions in
the chat in chess 24 or in the YouTube
channel and happy to to answer
everything alright so the idea is that I
play and I also do commentary on my
moves that's the idea right so we can
learn something today hopefully and okay
so I'm gonna take for example UK with UK
so yes so it goes for d4 I'm gonna go
native six probably I'm going for the
Kingston young one of my favourite
openings here and g6 cuz it's pretty
dynamic and it's pretty unbalanced and
there's a lot of tactics going on so
he's going for Knight c3 I need 40 main
line gonna reply with d6 which would be
2 on short Castle and then if he goes
not f3 I'm my plan was to go Bishop g4
but he goes for this Bishop d3 language
is pretty interesting so now there are a
couple of ways of playing if v is the
standard move here so normally white
closes the center with d5 and then 98 is
interesting aiming to go for f5 in the
next move but also I think 9 s6 in you
know to go night after d7 he goes for g4
Wow is going all-in
so probably night c5 attacking efore
he's got to protect that
forepaugh maybe with Quincy to a live
with f3 let's see he goes f3 then I
could even try to go h5 in that position
but probably is going or he took on c5
that's a surprise call normally this
dark square Bishop is actually pretty
pretty strong so now I'm gonna block on
daesik with my knight where I'm also
trying to break with f5 or f6 even maybe
f6 now f5 could be interesting fun ok
let's just play in 96 still not possible
for him to go h5 because g5 is hanging
right so it's gonna protect that and I
also have the b5 break in this position
I could also try to go a 6 + b5 stuff
like that it goes for Nara 3 alright so
maybe it's time to break with f6 or not
also be some g4 is quite interesting but
then maybe he could try to go 98 or
something like that
his idea is probably to go age five in
the next move but I'm not afraid that so
I could just try to go Bishop d7 in
order to go a 6 b5 after 85 I could try
maybe rook e8 and after 86 my bishop can
go to h8 or even f8 both seem playable
and 85 all right so go go Luke II 8
whenever he even if he manages to bring
a queen to the H file and then take on
g6 after x 2 x e6 my keen is very very
safe on f8 not very safe but it's it's
all right over there okay yes so as I
told you my plan is to strike with b5 at
some point Queen d2 and now a6 with the
idea of going b5 the next move probably
is gonna stop that by playing a 4 that's
right and then I could try droop b8
maybe after a 5 I can still go b5 and if
you take some % I can even check with my
pawn or with my rook and then I will be
tagged in there be to pawn of course I
gotta be careful with this attack on the
key inside but I think I'm doing more or
less or right my knight on their six is
actually
monster he checks in g6 and now have two
options I could take even with my f1
that looks also really interesting and
but this is most not more natural to say
H 66 and then let's see he is brave
enough to go along castle in this
position because then b5 will be even
stronger right and for those who are in
the YouTube channel you will find a link
over there to challenge me on chess 24
he goes long castle Wow this is gonna be
extremely double-edged cause akka I
gotta go b5 here in this position I
gotta have I gotta find some counter
play it takes a takes and then probably
she should take on b5 otherwise I'm just
gonna play b4 maybe or even be take c4
right so Bishop takes p5 Bishop takes
Knight takes Knight takes rook takes b5
looks really double-edged the other
option is to go c4 in this position
which I like a lot because I don't want
to give my knight from B is 6 so my idea
is to take now with the be something he
takes back on b5 then I'll check with my
rook then of course my idea is gonna put
a lot of pressure on the b2 pawn right
let's say Queen B a twin b6 bring the
other rook from the e-file to the B file
at some point he's got to find a way of
for the attack on the key inside I don't
know so difficult how to bring the Queen
to the action right Queen e1 Queen g1
Queen H - looks pretty pretty slow and
we'll see we'll see what's going on
Seaforth and on 9h - in Bishop g4
managed to and Bishop g4 that looks good
I think I could go Queen c8 in that case
to protect you for that sounds
interesting so it goes Queen III and now
I think I'm just taking this guy on b5
probably his intend to go Queen h3 at
some point let's say 92 but then his g5
points also hanging so it's got to pay
attention to that guy - but I like 92
here it's pretty pretty double attack
still don't get what's going on here but
maybe I could try Bishop d7 back also c4
is hanging in that variation so I think
I did too is a good move actually
because I cannot go up each of these
semi ghost Knight h2 so maybe he'll
listen to you and all right so should do
something whoa these salmon looks
reasonable so I covered the h3 square a
cup of tea for and it goes 94 all right
so I think I should take here on g4
otherwise say is there's nine eight six
come here Knight f6 and Bishop b5 all
right I'm gonna go route b3 now whenever
he goes Queen h3 I'm just gonna take
this pawn on d5 and then my idea could
be Queen c7 and rook b8 and then start
putting pressure on the beach upon there
are also some Knight d5 ideas now which
are really really nice given the fact
that this knight on c3 spin so I'm gonna
go for this not be fine let's see it's
brave enough to take the knight of e5 I
don't think so because they struck III
just winning on the spot and then my
idea all rune bishop d1 that's nice
that's nice my rook is kind of trapped
so Knight c3 Bishop b3 and just
blundering on an exchange
so maybe rugby for it's not the end of
the wall maybe 92 night 92 yep look
before 92 that's interesting the other
idea is just to sacrifice on exchange
I'm gonna go for this so 94 and then
Bishop takes me three seat XV 3 and then
Queen a 8 is an idea in order to
continue with Queen a 1 right so takes
takes this which is actually quite good
this good defense in peace so Queen is
free just queen a queen 817 f8 and this
King it's more or less safe on f8 and
yeah so the plan is quite easy for me so
Queen a 8 Queen a 1 and then try to
break with c6 or something like that ok
he goes 92 all right Queen a a knight XD
for Queen a 1 check King D - Queen B -
check and then I'll collect this guy
on g4 I think that's a good idea give me
that give me that baby
so Quimby troop remove it's got to go to
d3 I guess or d1 but this looks
completely losing for him so it takes d4
now this rook is joining the party here
in e4 right
so probably Queen d2 but then Queen b1
and queen taxi for this just looks just
very very good for Queen d3 maybe you
know the tube f3 oh that's a free queen
so give me that D takes c3 hanging he's
got to resign right thanks for the game
good game would Yuki got a lot of
challenges here so let's see when I'm
playing now we go down feed a master
over there and okay let me win 2200
player and all right I have you guys
here on the YouTube channel and also in
chess 24 so I'm gonna go for now not
Keaney for that's not a good move Knight
f3 and then I'm gonna good okay he goes
for the petrov one of the most solid
defenses gonna take this guy here on e5
probably g6 94 Wow Queen e2 then he's
got to play d6 or queen e7 right I'm
gonna take this guy on e4 he's going 46
and then this is just a pawn app but
there is a lot of compensation going on
here in this line so D takes e5 and then
I think I'm supposed to take with my
pawn but then I could also take with my
queen Queen takes Queen takes then
knight c6 Bishop b5 Bishop d7 okay let's
take with the pawn here Nexus 6 probably
and then I could try Bishop b5 to see he
plunders with Queen e5 I don't think so
you see this t-shirt it's I I bought it
in I want to see this ice hockey match
with the blues
it has the names of all players you know
it's just I never saw an ice hockey game
before it's just amazing these guys are
so strong so strong and so fast okay
Bishop e5 prolly is going for Bishop d7
and then just long short Castle here I'm
ideas just to continue development with
Bishop f4 but then he could take on e5 I
could think no I don't think so because
picture before Knight takes e5 20x e5
Queen takes e5 Bishop d7 intermediate
moves on let's go for this Bishop f4 of
course my next move is Knight c3
bringing the knight to the center and
also I mean to jump to d5 at some point
why not and then bring the roots to the
center to e1 and e1 he goes for f5 I'm
not gonna take a pass and of course I'll
go maybe Queen III but then eight six
looks very very interesting but also I
have this Bishop c6 and Queen a7 ideas
okay I'm gonna go for Queen III also I'm
straightening Bishop g5 right now so
it's gotta protect that with eight six
which is also threatening g5 I have to
figure out what to do next I could take
and c6 Bishop takes and Queen a7 and
probably be six tier and then I think
he's got a lot of compensation over
there and he's getting smaller less safe
right so I don't know after eight six
I could try even Bishop d3 in order to
answer g5 with f4 it's got some Queen c5
IPS over there Queen before Wow
all right very very interesting so
attacking this guy there Knight c3
probably wants to go Bishop c5 okay I'm
gonna go for this so Knight c3 Bishop c5
and that probably queen g3 is
interesting and also threatening is six
at some point so Bishop c5 let's say
queen g3 Queen txb - looks very very
risky I don't know if it's going to work
for here or not but I'm gonna try this
Queen g3 also a six is coming taking on
these c7 sorry at some point someone
asks if you recommend any
books or paid memberships on any apps
okay okay I work for chess 24 guys and
we have a lot of interesting video
series from best chess players in the
world but I've had to recommend you a
book I would say I really loved the 7
how you call in English the seven sins
in chess or something like that from
Jonathan Rosen Rosen is actually a
really amazing book it's actually meant
daily chess or something yeah it's the
first book I read and I really enjoyed
it I read it with like 20 years ago or
something or 15 years ago but I really
loved it yes that true yeah we merged
like like a few months ago or something
so not me but I'll be probably doing
some stuff for them too in the future so
yeah so play Mac knows disabled just
only for weird groans yeah yeah we are
all partners yeah
yes okay so should I do now mmm-hmm
mmm-hmm 92 for should be careful with
that I should be careful with this 92 so
it's not looking very very good for me
now I'm gonna go teenage one just not to
blunder the kwid and she was threatening
Queen c3 right yeah Queen c3 was afraid
I could still survive with twin takes c3
but okay 96 it's got an ID block hater
there blocker whatever you say
so Bishop c1 I'm gonna go back explain
really well now protecting b2 a probably
intend to go a3 in the next move also
Queen f3 could come to play to attack at
5 but not really knowing him so let's
see a3 my bishop is doing nothing on c1
so I better rush it's also 20 seconds up
now rook f8 gonna go a3 let's see where
he goes
probably Queen a tree is also
interesting so target in 87 also desire
now
could be interesting in the future maybe
Queen C for attacking my rook on f1
looks very bad for me actually
I like his position even though I nap on
up he's got a lot of compensation here
Quincy for probably is a good move and
then I have to see what to do probably
King g1 just coming back there's no 92
now so it goes Queen b6 that allows b49
a4 and okay Knight be for Bishop d4 we
should beat you so at least I managed to
develop my pieces so I'm gonna go for
this so before he can't take on F 2 D 1
is covered actually so those tactics are
not working so Bishop b4 and then Bishop
b2 finally I'm able to bring the rooks
on a senator rook e1 rook e1 at some
point to protect e5 also Knight a force
an idea still I like his position but we
are getting better now exactly
f4 now I'm gonna go hmm
Queen g4 he's got Bishop e5 there but
all right so Queen g4p should be fine
just rook e1 and then put some pressure
on the ephah this night only six is
hanging as well there are some 94 ideas
as well if he takes on e5 I think 94 is
actually pretty good if it takes only
594 Queen a6 Bishop takes Queen takes
and then Queen 2 x e6 I think I'm just
winning if it takes on e5 it doesn't
take on e5 1094 is also a threat this
night on e6 is actually is suffering
quite a lot so we should take c3 we
should take c3 and I started when I was
6 I think I started with a a lot of
sports I tried football Chinese but then
I won the under-16 national championship
so I I stayed with chess who is your
favorite chess players or my first chess
players that's easy to say I mean
to say that my favorite players magnus
carlsen is kind of you know but I really
like his his chest and also his attitude
when he is playing tournaments because
he's always gone for the win
and there was this let's say crisis in
chess like 20 years ago or something
with everybody was making throws on
stuff like that and Magnus Carlsen is
just so aggressive and and I really like
his his attitude okay so what should I
do here okay I'm gonna go route c1 he
started a success angle so if we exit
frequent takes c6
so what ago we should beat you and then
play see four he took that they're gonna
take this guy in e6 and then I got a
passport on the e-file so maybe I should
support it by rookie one and then stop
pushing
otherwise I'm running out of time rook
f7k Queen d5 centralizing my queen that
looks good also aim to go east six in
the next movement finally try to speed
up so he's got 30 seconds only got 51
seconds this looks good to me also rooty
one threatening checkmate on the
background okay I'm happy to trade
Queens now rook t1 offering files rook
e1 let's go there rook e1 he's going
through key it probably and then group
t3 finally taking this F pawn ever give
me that give me that rook a string now
we gotta play fast and the rook on c3 is
doing a fantastic job protecting
everything and then bringing the key
into the center so rook c5 as well then
these kids come to f3 to e3 kicking this
route back from there King III rook e1
just rookie 3 sorry rook c3 and then we
can start pushing our pawns on the Kings
side we've got three versus two so I'm
gonna push King g5 and then f4 f5 and
then this looks completely winning all
right very nice game let me win but he
was very close rookie 3 and rookie 7 and
he's got to resign prediction
all right man thank you for the game and
we got here know the challenge from God
where did you stop Ling wait me yes how
are you 21 years ago okay six years ago
okay you proved quite a lot you're 2,200
now just about yeah okay awesome so you
do something else besides yes you stop
oh yeah I'm studying English at a
Webster University buffing I don't know
I'm so I spend a lot of my time on chess
okay sounds good
okay be fine yeah who's the highest
rated player you have played Pippin well
I played a lot of big guns I played I
played uh nice kitty
I played Hari Krishna and a ban choke
and I don't know ponomaryov for example
there's a triple repetition here so 95
Queen a 496 Queen B 3 but we're going
for the win now Knight c3 7 and then I'm
gonna show Castle here then protect this
knife with c6 which looks actually
interesting and then son idea could be
Knight b6 in order to bring the other
night back to D if I'm actually I saw
this in jungle stuff some video series
in chess 24 so Bishop d3 probably and
then 8 6 looks good
so another to combat the T 5 squared and
mighty ice ago night e 2 D 5 and finally
alright it goes a for pretty name
knowing move I don't sing I am I'm
trying to go a 5 and also the be
Foursquare nice actually really really
tasty so night 85 in a vertical night
before bring the other night 25 be 54
even Bishop f5 could be an idea he's
playing really fast so I better start
playing faster though so Bishop g4 now
it's actually quite annoying
it's got night b7 over there so
I'm gonna protect that guy with Queen c7
and then of course he allows me to go
BTW for I would be doing quite well here
is there a reason you played a 92 d7 and
I mean d5 instead of not be to d5
because it seems more natural to me to
play nice so you mean the when when you
played 92 d5 yes yeah well we wanted to
bring this map back to you yeah yeah
that was also possible of course okay
mmm now he's threatening this guy on b7
bishop takes and then if I move the
bishop to okay anyway I'm going Bishop
g4 so takes takes Queen b7 Queen B 797
Bishop b3 ds3 and it's not a you see
this position not easy at all okay give
me that give me that
and rukia a droopy age also night before
gonna go through t8 so he takes on d5 I
am able to take back with my rook it's
been really fast a Spanish guy he beat
me what
he beat me already so I better be
careful here route d5 this p6 Knights
kind of hanging so it goes wouldn't c3
and now Knight c8 if I go to tea 7 days
Luke is 7 which is extremely annoying
so now Queen b3 attacking this guy that
aren't gonna go b6 just go away so it's
got to go back to e4 and now rook e8
putting a lot of pressure on the default
port also some c5 ideas are really
interested in for example now c5 looks
good so he can take because they struck
t1 and then we're putting a lot of
pressure on this d4 pawn probably is
going to fall in the next move
so route takes rook takes rook takes and
then there are no background problems
yet there could be in the future I could
also try to bring my knight to e7 into
6a if he doesn't do anything about this
Luke and d1 hang in and he's 20 seconds
up in the club or someone asks to my
accessible here is yeah who's your
favorite chess player probably Korchnoi
cord annoy hmm I just was accused
yeah he was playing high level
in his 70s or something it was crazy
exactly
also just his fighting spirit he always
was very upset when he lost yeah Queen
d7 let's see he blunders something night
c4 okay this should be looking pretty
pretty nice for us and then just bring
the king bring the King pepper
come on bring the kid I'm gonna go f6 oh
no checks no checks right Kim D 714 C 6
and then b5 probably be 5 I can go be 5
now takes takes we're running out of
time should be fast she's keen seasick
so there's no Maxie six kids C for just
96 I'm gonna go a 4 here so 94 96 come
on we're almost there we're almost there
Kim D 5 centralising are keen so night C
for now tacking be 293 just losses on
the spot we're gonna take this guy no
not yet it's 96 94 give me that give me
that baby 94 93 95 and then we win we're
winning Keaney for just 96 to protect
that guy so deep for 94 that's good so
we are managing 84 84 83 h2 h1 then I'm
gonna collect that guy so I'm not losing
and then they should be quite okay here
their gain of 6 and Queen g7 checkmate
poof okay so I'm gonna add set
another challenge from from from all
right let's take some strong player like
PD knows flow got from Greece ever been
to Europe no I've actually never been
out of the country
ok alright so I'm gonna go for d4 now
and Knight of 6 c4 I mean in the states
that I've just been to Miami which
almost everybody speak Spanish over
there and I've been to say Lewis and
somewhere else not really just some
reason Miami I think and this time I'm
going to New York for for a week after
this residence here in st. Louis so
actually my Spanish friends are joining
me over there for a week and my brother
too so should be a lot of fun did you go
to Miami for chess I wouldn't actually
to to record some videos with linear
dingus we were so lucky that we have
some friends they work like with some
betting stuff and they gave us some free
tickets to see neva versus feather Miami
Masters 10 is the finals and it was so
awesome we are so stupid that we made it
late and then we just saw like four or
five games you went to Vegas I went to
see the Tennis Masters with Dominguez
and two more friends you nasty Quezada
you probably know him here yeah yeah it
was pretty awesome
so I'm gonna take this guy with my night
here you also came to Peru yes of course
I love her South America Latin America
so nice where are you going to play a
tournament in Portugal actually I played
the Portuguese league for like six or
seven years I have good friends over
there in Portugal I don't know why but
every Portuguese can't speak perfect
Spanish but we Spanish people we can't
speak a word of Portuguese we're
neighbors in Spanish Spanish it
Spain in particular so what should I do
here Saudi takes a finite takes Knight
takes and then Queen sexy - very
interesting stuff so how about if I just
take with my knight Knight takes e5 so
neck take spontex quintic c2 e takes f6
that was my idea and then his pawn
structure will be completely ruined on
the key inside position should be around
equal to but maybe you can go 97 okay -
kanji - and then I'm gonna take an f6
and this should be quite okay for us so
G takes f6 I think I can just play be
free for example or even yeah b3 looks
good even Queen c7 has to be okay for
for white here because c6o I'm gonna
collect that guy over there and we're
just opponent a healthy poni
all right so Quincy free just trading
Queens looks good also route d1 Queen B
- nothing that happens to me in front is
gonna go for this queen c3 and then
bring the rooks too deep wanna be one
create some pressure on b7 there's
always pressure over there and probably
a four in order to go a 5 from fix the
structure over there looks good - Bishop
c4 is quite annoying here okay he even
go for this
I see now his point rook do you want and
then mm-hmm like this gotta go for this
so takes exhibition p3 I could go even
group t4 over there I think so
Group D 4 and then after c5 rook g4
check and then I no time to go any five
probably the best move here is a five
because c5 then this gives me some free
time also b7 now is a weakness so maybe
I should just take that guy also 85
looks really really good
a5 now it's gonna protect this guy in b7
and then I can bring my piece is Mikey
at some point has to be brought to the
center juicer
probably it's the best move now should
that go mission takes me seven that was
a I know that point for free for me
because now after root beer he's
threatened to go be six until he can
survive in that position yes yes that's
good
alright so what should I do now I'm
gonna give I'm gonna play route 84 here
so to see what he goes we should be for
now and probably Bishop d3 that's my
idea to put some pressure over there but
still he can go b6 right he goes there
but then rook age five twins on other
pump maybe still rook t8 in that
position
alright let's just bring dick the King
to the center so I don't have so much
time c4 it maybe it's good just planted
this I should go and see four wow that's
heavy stuff so I'm gonna take this pawn
on c5 it was just bluff this Bishop e3
there is how it's got only 20 seconds
and then this is just completely waiting
now this is completely waning and guys
yeah
Ruby 5 c4 c5 King e3 e4 that looks
really really good
alright so Ruby 7 go back give me that
baby Luke 8 7 okay
c4 go back and then I'll collect this
guy in 86 and too many points yeah
King g7 just rotate 7 nothing happens
Ruki 17 FAS rookie 3 ok good game PD
knows you know I actually need to train
let's play against a feeder master I
need to train him because we are
organizing interesting for a really
strong tournament it's a we call it the
bond tablets Cup yeah I watched some of
the first round jobs yeah and there's
50k in prices and a lot of top players
and play including Magnus Carlsen
in the next round I face pants Walia who
is from Grand Master from Georgia it's
got like 2600
so LaVon yeah LaVon Ponce Walia and if I
beat him I would be playing Magnus
Carlsen so I'm gonna prepare
that much like crazy and then because it
could be a lot of fun if I managed to to
play against Magnus Carson get crush of
course 9 0 but still you know I'm gonna
go for here this is pretty typical as
well trying to break the pond chain over
there and then c4 could be week after
some trades over there
so II for probably is gonna take here or
maybe 92 is also interesting right so
night takes then route takes and see for
is hanging so these bishops are quite
good this Bishop could come to f5 at
some point then attack the the route can
be one Bishop on g7 is actually quite
strong as well so they are not so many
squares the suit is a little bit better
for black yeah I mean I played actually
this exact position in a classical game
and I remember it was really tough of a
white you to play over the board he
found a nice way though so Bishop d2 and
yeah okay I'm gonna take this guy here
and then play Queen f6 the queen is in
the best diagonal in the board now there
are some 19 for ideas also it goes back
to be one I could play Bishop f5 to
actually provoke efore that's an idea to
because this Bishop won't be so strong
anymore and also it comes back to be one
I got this a 2 squared to bring my roots
right
so Queen f6 route p1 and p4 is also
quite nice it's a beautiful I like this
one let's go G for attacking it you so
you do any other sport just it just you
consider chances for yeah me just that's
why our levels yeah yeah yeah I mean
could be extremely tiring right 5/2 and
it doesn't have so many squares
maybe beefy looks like I'm getting
something after rooting for or even
Brooke a tool over there rookie - it's
actually quite nice because I'm not only
threatening this each party to was
Bishop c2 yourself is this whole swath
right there hmm
now give me that baby give me that
who's your daddy Italian chess play
Italian feelin master he resigned okay
thanks a lot for the game I'm gonna keep
playing against Harl giddy from the
Netherlands maybe he is get his brother
punished kill his brother so I'm gonna
go eat for ya Chauncey it's actually
extremely tiring if you play like nine
rounds tournament in two games per day
it's just very very tough so most of
players actually muscle players in the
elite they they train like they go to
the gym or they 97 Seaforth in this is
considered to be the best here and 94
and there are some crazy stuff here
going on there's some crazy stuff which
of course I don't remember so I'm just
gonna go we should be three nah let you
capture this guy eat 65 this is the
usual recipe and 9f5 probably i just
didn't play well enough so Bishop d2 now
I want to take this guy on b5 it takes
okay give me that
and after 80-85 Bishop text b5 with the
temple
I know that during one of his matches
Karpov lost like 30 pounds I think it
was against Korchnoi mm-hmm he was
having a problem so yes
chess is definitely physically demanding
yeah
actually rather on articles well I think
it was from a newspaper here in saying
we serve I don't know from but carry on
okay carry on
fine [ __ ] I won I was interviewed there
and he was talking as well about this
marriage for very interesting
so putting pressure on g2 g3 probably
looks good enough so he's forced to go
back to f5 probably and then my B has to
go Bishop d3 so stopping Bishop is six
cuz the knight on f5 is hung Gainesville
so Bishop ft3 looks good and then I
don't g6
doesn't go anywhere right so probably
his intent to go f5 here and then trying
to create some sort of attack x4 is
actually interesting man he's got the H
someone asks who taught you how to play
chess well I mean my father he taught me
how to play chess and then I went to
this school classes in Spain and then
that's how I started then I started to
go to the Chess Club
we had a Chess Club in my time in
Granada it's a very beautiful town guys
say you go to Europe I recommend my city
we have the most visited monument in
Spain which is called the Alhambra it
was the last
Pallister the muslims had in in europe
before they were kicked out from the
catholics like back in the 15th century
1492 I should stop talking [ __ ] and
okay go Bishop e4 okay not that easy
that easy
I'm gonna go Queen c2 here so putting
pressure on g6 even though I'm not so
sure if I if I want to take on g6
because this baby is extremely important
here in this position
and when I go a rookie one probably rook
c1 also before be fine could be an idea
and this Knight is doing nothing on a
tree I just want to get him back in the
action maybe 95 intending 97 at some
point look up six he's going for it come
on guy give me a break okay I'm gonna go
95 bishop on e6 I will just go a four
all right so Bishop a tree I'm gonna go
look II one probably Queen f8 is this
IDF but then I could just play Bishop b4
or Bishop c3 so just protecting f2 f3
okay I'm not so sure about that move I'm
gonna go a 7 so not to blunt the top on
and then Bishop e3 and Knight c7 could
be an idea also Queen c7 trading Queens
which actually without creates this is
much safer so maybe I'm going for this
b-52 I see your idea man
so do you want to go Queen d7 so let's
not allow that and play Bishop f5
controlling this important day Ana's who
taught orange is sure to to two places
weren't sure guy invented chess forty
seconds you have to play fast man
otherwise I'm gonna flag you that's my
best skill and chance to black people I
don't know how to play properly but I
flagged like help so we should be free
we should be six check followed by Queen
c7 looks good too
not a faint all right she wants to play
g6 probably but I'm not okay so I'm
gonna go Bishop e3 Jonathan how's it
gonna happen
it's good alright it's kind of right he
wants you check lifelong dream to crash
a chest 24th Street hmm okay so we
should be for Queen d7 and Queen a tree
this is his idea I know he is going
anywhere I don't but I'm gonna just go
going back to d3 I'm playing Queen c6
and then try to grab this room
all right so win ce7 queenie at Quincy
six trying to trade everything 26 takes
takes 97 give me that baby
Queenie 8 when I ate sorry and it's got
a resign awesome I won every game but I
was struggling at some point too okay
let's say hi for a second okay cool all
right so oxy eight from Mexico Mexico is
a really nice contraband the food in
Mexico is just just amazing I'm going
back there in December for tournament
and it's so good and the party is good
to do Mexico the one the party parties
yeah people are really really nice in
Mexico - it's one of my favorite
countries probably my top three are you
there mr. oxy eight actually sauce also
this kind of perfume yeah yeah also
actually the show xf4 Wow okay I'm gonna
go for this gambit and so f takes d5 d6
that's a the after eat X is six visit
xt6 not a 3g5 that was my idea okay
he didn't want to go to go for this and
then he gave me a free pawn so I'm happy
I'm gonna go native 6 from g6 Bishop g7
and develop that way what's your
favorite opening well my favorite
opening was the King's Indian for a lot
of time and also the Philly door with
the black pieces
I almost played exclusively the Philidor
until I became I am the engines were not
so sophisticated and people didn't find
a way against my filly though but now
with stockfish and all these stuff you
know it's not that easy to
to go for the Philidor in every game but
still one of my favorite openings so
here I'm gonna go 94 maybe 94 96 e4
Bishop takes on c3 and my bishop in on a
while is trapped so I'm just gonna
develop 97 stuff like that rook e8
position should be alright for black I
mean we have a lot of space advantage
here so whose daring just really for
chat is somebody there in the chessani
for chat yes a lambda must be one of the
most prettiest places in the world
that's true you guys don't believe me
just go there you will be extremely
impressed it's actually full of
Americans and Japanese people every day
and you have to buy tickets like two or
three months in advance did you say
Japanese people yes where'd they all
hombro yeah tourism from from Japan in
in Spain that University so we're gonna
go eight six to cover g5 and also we
have what we call tap ass you know what
tapas are okay so in my city if you get
your there a coke in a bar Africa for
example alright you get a small amount
of food for free MBC's called tapas okay
like what what kind of food like for
example a burger or even some meat with
fries or fish seafood and stuff like
that mmm but the thing is in my serie
they are for free so basically it's one
of the cheapest city and see this in in
Spain Granada actually how much you pay
here for for a room in the in Saint
Louise in the center let's say in this
area I know this area is one of the
prettiest right but how much don't you
how much do you pay isn't it like $200 a
night or something
two hundred dollars per month I know a
night I'm not going I'm you know I mean
rentals are
come on I mean I know a hotel does I
don't know I lived with a grandmaster
and Webster for okay it was a pretty
terrible place but it was like $250 a
month actually
oh yeah it's a cheap probably okay yeah
it was quest like if that's likes me
okay now come on but I mean a normal
flat here okay should be much more
expensive I guess you're trying to sell
me your place but here in st. Louis you
should probably pay like at least if I
had a box per room right or something
like that yeah okay so it might see the
you can get the room for 100 years in
the center so it's actually quite cheap
come on a month a month all right so I
don't know what am I doing here but I
think it's got a nice position actually
his queen is still pretty passive and
z-one but okay so Knight e5 I'm gonna go
beat you by five here or what should I
do here maybe we should be fine let's
put some pressure on e5 he can take on
d7 of course and nothing happens Queen
taxi 795 Queen c7 still like my position
cuz screen and c1 is basically doing
nothing so I'm gonna go be sure before
he takes I'll take back with my point
and then the this pawn indeed who could
be our witness right so we should eat
ooh he wants to go d3 okay I can take
this now give me that takes takes takes
takes and I'm happy with this position
18 seconds 4 x8 all right thank you very
much for the game I'm gonna continue
playing against let's say for example
let's say this guy
from Germany I was living actually in
Germany for three years
nice country I was doing my PhD over
there was working as a researcher at the
University oh what's your PhD in Applied
Mathematics I am a simple engineer as
well but I decided to do a PhD in
applied mathematics in Hamburg
University of Hamburg still the culture
is a little bit different from Spanish
culture but it's a nice country you have
a lot of working opportunities the
transport system is amazing the food is
not my favourite but all right Germans
are really really nice really polite
people and don't be late
you have an appointment you have a date
something don't believe that they'll
kill you and of course as a Spanish I
was used to be late but I learned how to
behave in German all right so it's not
there so I'll have to abort the game and
okay so let's play a really strong
player let's play these 2908 spell from
Spain he was here he was here he left I
know he's here 2949 so now we we have to
be careful all right so we got the black
pieces let's see what he does efore d4
are you there mr. ice belts this is a
basque name actually basque country is a
region in the north another so i'm gonna
go five here let's see what he does
knight c6 and Bishop c4 the Italian
you're not gonna play the Philidor no no
no well in the next thing I'll go for
the Philidor okay and here I'm not gonna
take on e4 this is the other variation
where after Bishop takes Knight takes
bishop f7 and here T 595 check King e6
Queen text before and queen afraid this
an idea from Lebanon Orion and this
ending is considered to be actually
equal so
you could go on shore castle there
everything so sea fog let's go
c5 f3 Knight f6 I don't know man I don't
remember anything
g6 here in order to develop this guy and
the Gangnam is considered to be equal
but I lost a game a classical game in a
close tournament with this line so I
better be careful alright he's
threatening to go Knight b5 checked you
probably probably shot castle was not
good for some reason but I can't
remember now all right I think I'm
forced to take here I really like white
position you like it
white yeah yes like words better yep so
my bishop is terrible his Knight is
perfectly fine place on e5 this is the
way I lost that game so I'm gonna try to
break in the center with c5 this looks
terrible for me man
oh man c5 let's go dee texted 5 I could
have attacked with my keen my thoughts
with c4 and then try to create some sort
of counter play here and with b5 and
stuff be 5a 5b for this is my idea but
then of course he has a three bases to
here on the kingside and then he could
push quite hard a3 this gives me the be
for break then I could even think about
sacrificing the pawn Oh neither three
where are you going
where are you going my man where are you
going I'm gonna go route a 7 not so sure
about this [ __ ] before 95 d4 looks good
let's go before I just try to create
some counter play here Tex takes rook b8
yeah at the end route p8 it's got some
rookie want you I don't know this looks
tricky also before now that's too much
right that's too much that's too much
oh gosh okay okay seven let's go for
okay seven this was not my initial idea
of course I think yeah worse now just so
why did why didn't you like her gay to
be a bouquet to be eight I was afraid of
rookie seven weeks before she said yeah
okay I'm going to be seven now I think
bouquet one is actually quite good no
dad
all right hmm okay we should be for 95
right yeah 95 just been so terribly now
it six takes takes and then I take on V
4 and then I have some drawing chances
but I'm of course much worse now much
worse maybe a little bit worse yeah not
much so haha look me - now let me -
intended to go after the f2 pawn now
we've got some counter play if he plays
rookie - I could even be much better
because I traded in Kingdom - give me
that
Oh give it up come on let's go let's go
rookie seven rook c8 rooks yeah that's
good
then C 3 C 2 we're winning I don't know
how we managed to get back in this game
but we did it and then C 3 C 2 and C 1
lag is good man life is so good so take
some king c3 and King b2 and it's got to
resign in this position well they can't
keep playing but come on really
really
you want to flag me okay we want 20
points it's nice I feel like very few
people like no rook in games well like
if you have chess that a lot of people
don't really know it's actually one of
the most trickiest parts in there in the
game right so people tend to think like
okay the most complicated part is the
middle game but rook and games are just
so difficult to play a lot of people
assume they work in games you just draw
on
yeah they don't really need to study for
exactly there are so tricky
let's play some someone asks what's your
music taste like I mean I can listen to
everything basically so I like rock I
like fob I like classical music when I'm
working on something
I like Latin music a lot but cha-cha
salsa even reggaeton when I go out so
you know there's also a lot of requests
for this
Ratatat Spanish broadcast so but you
guys will kick me from the states
[Music]
okay go d6 now here this is the mainland
in the fianchetto variation so he goes
now t4 we are in the pan of variation
with this knight c6
that many possibilities now for black
for white here you can go d5 and then
black said years ago 95
you're gonna go Bishop f4 this is a
great very trendy nowadays rupee 1 and B
1 should be a mistake already because
Bishop f5 comes with the tempo right and
then it's got to go back to a 1 and for
sure this is not White's idea and this
in this position and I also love hip-hop
you know Spanish hip-hop Spanish rap
mm-hmm so I never really understood I've
never studied this these kind of plans
with 96 or be a b5 like what is by
trying to do with with those moves yeah
basically at some point after b5 C takes
me 5 80 85 you could create some
pressure on the queenside
but it's it's hard to understand that
the years we it's it's pretty weird I
agree
so I'm gonna go 94 here so Knight takes
Bishop takes and I already put pressure
on the T four point then I can continue
with a five or B 5 do you want to become
a GM people are asking oh right what do
I want - yes
can I probably I mean my real goal is
maybe and to become an I am one day okay
are you playing tournaments I recently
just got back into it
um you know I have a few comments coming
up the spice coat spice cabin this is in
web series me I was invited once
actually
but actually the spice program was
taking part in another city I think it
was in Texas that time because Suzanne
was there at Texas a day right yeah
Texas - yeah yeah they offered me a
scholarship but then I decided to stay
in Europe because my family friends
stuff like that
I play I've played every year for the
past few years and I always end up it's
so strong that I always end up with like
two out of nine and I always only lose a
little bit of poison no I said really
strong that tournament right some genes
playing there's not that post anuman
anymore it's an open tournament uh
there's like a rating a minimum rating
requirement ah it's kind of the lower
you are the more you have to pay but
it's a very it's a very strong can turn
them in alright
and then enough to spice cap why are you
playing um oh actually before the spice
Cup I'm playing in an invitational with
some masters here yeah the club yeah
okay cool so I'm hoping to make master
in those two tournaments and then I
don't know I don't really know what it
takes to become an ion yeah you have to
play a lot for sure and then the norms
are quite tough to achieve but then I
mean you have to play a lot of
tournaments to have chances yeah that's
a way I learned just playing playing
playing playing playing it's important
to study books of course and stuff like
that and but it's more important I would
say to play
I'll try to visit this Marshall chess
club in there and you'd agree famous
yeah I'll try to play some blitz over
there chair okay I'm gonna stop see fine
which is pretty annoying in this
position so my idea is to get this knife
back in the action maybe 97 and 95 I
could also try to break with f5 in this
position so I think I have a nice
position but still it's not possible to
increase the pressure and on c4 so next
move Knight c5
let's see wants to give me this dark
square bishop which is very very
important in these positions night c5
then probably Bishop 866 idea okay so
now I'm gonna go queen c8 targeting the
a triple let's see we want to go h4
which is probably the best move here in
this position or g4g for consits a lot
of squares this effort square now
playing effort would be almost
impossible for him because now this
which will become a monster here so I
think I'm gonna go f5 anyway yes let's
go at 5 here take stakes and then my
bishop will be extremely active there he
wants to take everything yes the
performance she means for anion or me is
24:54 GM is 26:26 at 2,600 sir
so what's up guys where are you up to Oh
g5 he decided to close the position that
but then f4 takes takes and then this
point is hanging but also the in four
squares really really interesting for
him so not gonna play f4 here probably
four should be interesting so now I've
got the d3 squared also the e5 square
for my bishop even my night could be
retreated at some point to e5 to attack
the c4 pawn so now I'm gonna take this
guy here rook takes Queen takes nothing
that happens to me this title h2 is
basically doing nothing all right so I'm
gonna try to improve
my bishop baby bishop the queen probably
so Queen d7 is my next move I'm gonna
bring the screen to the senator if I
were I will be attacking this pawn on c3
this looks very very nice for black now
and yeah it's gonna be hard for him to
protect everything so Queen B 586 second
always go back to 88 and then keep
putting pressure on c3 and after rook
takes rook takes and he's running out of
time takes takes takes and teach and c3
takes takes root b7 I can go Bishop a5
so let's go for this boom
also f4 was maybe better was better you
know you know how we call the f-bomb in
Spanish broadcasts Facundo which is
lucky right it's a could be but it's a
it's a Spanish name oh I see all right
I'm gonna be 5 + f4 could be an idea
here Bishop f1 so Facundo is literally
just a first date yeah yeah yeah it's a
I know that the ginger Jim cause the H
pawn here hurry yeah I know that's ok
I'm gonna go before first thing need to
take it there and see it free and then
he goes look b7 Bishop a5 aim to go
Bishop e6 trapping the Queen now this
cannot be good III it shouldn't be good
all right let's play a four here to go
fish about five 10 seconds for him his
night is so bad yeah he's not just doing
nothing and then Ruby says you pay five
this nice idea we should be 600 I'm
bishop CA that's that's my whole point
maybe 94 okay even go for this and then
I'm gonna collect this beautiful rook
and probably collect his pawns to
rookie five fruit g5 route DC no no I
was almost removing
did you just drop my boob I dropped my
rock okay get out seven nothing happens
nothing bad happens yet but rookie a
rookie five that's my plan B five all
right this should be actually for kundo
doesn't sound so well in English right
[ __ ] okay let's take this mr. norman
challenge from the state's CEO slate
nice picture
so I'm gonna go not at six and then
let's stick with our kings in them
Bishop g7 let's see where he goes okay
he 46 now that three main line and I'm
gonna play Bishop g4 I played this
against you the other day in a blitz
game right it wasn't made me against you
onething
okay 97 I played Bishop e2 Bishop g5
yeah so 90 Sun basically the idea nice
after short castle to go knight c6 and
then after d5 you want to take on c3 you
want to take on f3 first Bishop takes
them 95 Bishop e2 and then Bishop c3b
takes c3 and then play this kind of
structure and of course you have White
has the bishop pair but then also White
has this twin pawn structure on the
Queen side and it's kind of closed round
yeah the position is pretty close so
that's why it's not bad for black here
so here I think okay I could go u5 d 5b
she takes f3 that's the idea and then 94
installing a beautiful night over there
so Bishop takes Knight e4 and then takes
X 95
yeah but then that's pretty bad actually
for some reason that I have to remember
and I think the move the best move there
is d3 for black that makes it and then
the engine size is minus 2 for black in
that
it's actually may be natural and but
yeah and then if you don't take a leave
for you go let's say Bishop d1 blacks
plan is to reinforce that man with c5
exactly after D takes B takes c6 and
then also we got the B file and then the
FI break sounds good
that's maybe have a family not yet okay
my mother might find my father
oh it's actually retiring he just
retired he is a chemistry teacher in
high school and he just finished a fine
looks good I'm gonna go for this my
mother is a nurse
my brother is telecommunication engineer
he also plays chess it's 2200 feeling
rating I think now he's losing a lot of
points in his playing like [ __ ] now
these days but he has a real job yeah
right so f5 you going back to c2e2 come
on
okay so I'm gonna go see five anyway D
takes c6 BTech c6 position looks pretty
pretty good for black here so take
stakes and the night hasn't got a proper
squared but what we'll have to go to d1
or a fourth something like that
therefore nice night take c200 e6 is
hanging tricky position tricky position
so queenie a7 protecting d6 now takes
forced to take back with my phone I
could have been think about taking on
YouTube that makes a lot of sense
actually that makes a lot of sense night
take C 2 and then d5 could be not so
sure takes yeah I'm gonna go route t8
here I'm playing with fire here he force
now he's threatenin Bishop d4 of course
so I gotta do something about this
this Queen could come to h4 maybe right
so we should take spontex and i could
jump now with my knight to c5 targeting
the d3 bishop so we have ended up in the
clock which is always good news and
takes takes is got to go back to e 2 and
now Knight c5 boom intended to come to
e4 93 mm-hmm tricky move
that was a good move it's quite annoying
so maybe queen g4 I feel like I'm gonna
blunder everything in this game I don't
know why I have this feeling sometimes
you just don't see anything and I have
this feeling now I hope this doesn't
become true and I have a view here in
case I'll only contribute more blunders
that's possible
alright so I have a nice plan here I
wanted to go okay can go h5 maybe h5
looks good eight-five Knight takes h5
don't do that pivot so Knight takes c3
Knight takes e4 young age 5 that could
be yeah that could be the solution to
all my problems 8 5 and h4 still the
bishop is not the best place in the
world but still protects d4 and it's a
nice defensive piece so h4 you gotta go
back to e - probably and then I could go
Luke f7 that's d4 is under attack
this doesn't look good oh my gosh
so c5 and rock a7 just winning upon but
they don't have some contemplate rookie
a rookie free they were fighting we are
still by we're still in the game here
against mr. normal name
mr. Naumann name what's that it's okay
rook e8 then he's supposed to take right
otherwise is neither mr. only to his
hanging so win takes I'll just take back
with my pawn I think we're 12 much
better now
awesome takes dice god takes no Ruka
fate it immediate check so I'm first to
take here and then all right
nice blockhead blocker here in d3 so
look III probably it's a good move Queen
d5 check key night seven Queen d6 we can
go there a tree let's he falls for that
so rookie 325 King Jack seven quindi 683
g3 rook takes g3 boom winning on the
spot so you're gonna fall for this my
friend come on go for it
still he can play after Queen d6 h3 can
go Queen d5 nothing happens of course
I'm gone during some stuff but then I
have d3 attacking be too threatening d2
has got one minute
so are you taking this guy here Duke up
you are brave enough you were so a tree
and let's see what you do now my friend
let's see what do you do now okay
g3 okay this is beautiful beautiful boom
are you sure you wanna go there oh oh my
god I mean if you went King each one you
had Ruggiero in the queen of three oh
right right right so I want to check me
this guy now when I check made these guy
but I don't see the way so hoody to key
me one not easy not that easy
Queen as free king a one this should be
move Queen 83 and then whoopty to just
simple chess threatening stuff
threatening Queen oh he could go 92
right he could go 92 here but then after
book t2 is in real trouble so rookie -
and now Queen d2 or free e - are coming
it goes for 93 then Queen e2 and Queen
c2 checkmate
it's got a resign here awesome this was
close yeah
[Music]
so books on Lewis just clarifier you and
you lose too many games yeah they would
say who is this putt sir what did you
guys bring from Spain come on this guy's
so stupid and he cannot even play chess
so let's go for Bishop b5 to Spanish
real Lopez I gotta play the Spanish yeah
so just to honor my country 97 just won
a real office you know he was a priest
oh yeah yeah it was a priest in the 1400
- exactly yeah t4 and I'll go Bishop b3
I mean CD CD 95 these people go here but
then oh these look so suspicious
I don't know but takes takes till he
manages to survive there all right all
right okay I'm gonna take you on d5 from
then place your castle and yeah sure
castle next in three rookie while
you like coffee no I'm still one of
those guys who drink
cacao with milk and stuff like that you
know cacao cacao how you say Coco Coco
yeah Coco
you mean like chocolate milk yeah
chocolate me I mean I know did you drink
any caffeine no no well just uh coke oh
yeah but you know I tried coffee so many
times you know what I said I just don't
like it
everybody looks at me when we and my
friends would go to coffee whatever what
do you want coffee coffee coffee coffee
tea and then I asked for chocolate all
right you know I couldn't live without
coffee yeah lots of people actually so
you're a coffee addict yes I'm a
self-admitted coffee yet okay
all right how's the coffee here in the
states it's a girl there is rubbish oh
it's rubbish tonight that's why I here
actually yeah so the best coffee is in
Colombia Guatemala and I mean amazing
coffee even though I didn't try it but
this is what everybody says I wanna
sacrifice whenever seven so badly right
now but I think it's just loosen so
takes 95 King g8 and then after Queen
has three double attacks Cup we should
be six protecting everything so like
interestingly so gonna go Bishop c2
let's see it goes for sure castle name
Queen d3 he could be in trouble actually
because there's no g6 so is forced to
play f5 here in this position then and I
want to shake the Queen side with a four
also after fi I'll have the e5 square
for my night I don't know what his is
planning to do here because of course
I'm threatening to take a b5 probably
Bishop d7 then Knight e5 attacking this
guy here sounds really good to me after
95 you're threatening 96 and 97 maybe
Bishop 83 yeah yeah that would be an
option to each other has pretty good
coffee I agree yeah even though I didn't
taste it it's got it why not talk we
with you yeah so 95 actually I was
studying in Italy with one of these
exchange programs when I was doing my
Master's I started in L'Aquila it's a
city which is close to Rome so I it was
my best year of course like Erasmus you
know Erasmus it's an exchange program oh
it's really it's really cool so I was
living with seven Italians in the same
flat and that's why I managed to learn
Italian quite fast seems like you've
been everywhere I mean I started in
Italy Poland and Germany during my
masters and then I lived in Germany for
three and a half years working there as
a researcher but apart from that just in
chess tournaments of course we have
trouble a lot
gonna I'm gonna pass with teenage one
and then I'm gonna go F takes and they
should be quite good for us we should be
three now we've got a nice diagonal over
there and when I bring this Bishop back
here to c5 okay he has to be blundering
too but ok what should I do here Bishop
c4 it's a fret so I'm gonna go look
after he's got 13 seconds he's not gonna
make it and I'm so happy about this so
Bishop before not to allow 95 Queen a1
just rook F 1
nothing happens we are a little bit
better so because we got the bishop part
so I'm gonna go I don't know if we're
better yes but it's not so bad yeah it's
the light squares yeah exactly so I'm
going to a queen bee one attacking f5
you fell for that
so give me that give me that
and now we are better but still not not
so clear so Queen f3 attacking this
night it's got to go back and eat 6
followed by Queen f7 no boom-boom
give me that Queen f7 thank you for the
game Miguel from Cuba Cuba is really
nice culture
I played six seven seven times over
there there is a nice tournament I
thought you guys can go there so easily
it's freaky for oh but the autonomy is
really nice and the Cubans are really
friendly I know the capablanca Memorial
is there yeah a couple my memory there's
a close tournament where super strong
players play about you later beings but
there's also this open tournament so
this is where I played actually I played
like five six times over there and I
have a lot of friends in Cuba let's play
against team cognitive
and someone asks if it was easy to learn
Italian when you were living with this
yeah I mean Italian is very similar to
Spanish actually so mmm the difficult
thing was to try to learn German German
I think in life is too short to learn
German I try to take a German class and
I withdrew pretty quickly I agree
so I mean my German is good enough to
survive was good enough to survive in in
Germany but the good thing about Germany
is that everybody speaks English so this
language efore is now this again trendy
because magnus carlsen played it a
couple of times for example against the
Amish Gideon the wall rapid in blitz
after Bishop c5 the idea is to take on
e5 and then d4
they take on f2 right I've taken enough
- is already here a blunder so you have
to take an e5 and d4 and then they are
Bishop b4 Bishop d6 after 95 Bishop f2
Kintex is to 95 d4 is already much much
better for for--why it's like +3 or
something all right so
[Music]
Oh d6 move was very passive yeah d6 was
passive I think at least you have to
take on d4 you want to go 46 because now
this is like a good version of the
King's Indian for me so I'm gonna go
with the usual plan with B 3 a 3 or even
88 straightaway because now a 4 is not
possible
after Bishop d7 I wouldn't go a 3
because a 4 and then I'm gonna Yoko B 3
right yeah especially 7 B 3 a 3
yeah exactly that's a slow plan but the
efficient so if I go 83 now a 4 is
actually quite interesting because my
pawn on e4 is hanging so I'm gonna go
beat three anyway yeah actually for you
gentlemen would be easier than for me
because a it's a it's possible solution
yeah yeah but for me I just wanted to
die
I only remember how to say like one
thing which is das is good this is good
this is good digger see guys like dude
in German digger yeah he's come this
conspira-con
ambition dosh of about Alex Ferguson no
it's it's too difficult
Oh accent actually I I not to say
something else
ich bin shark gross Meister I am a chess
grandmaster yeah yeah I'm chassis shock
in German so it's quite close mm-hmm
actually it's almost similar in every
language in Italian is kaki in Catalan
is
six no that's French its CAC's
in in Catalan but in Spanish is I don't
know why all right so I'm gonna go 91
you wanted to trade the dark square
bishop which is nice idea but I'm not
gonna allow him so this night is coming
to d3 in order to play c5 that's the
usual stuff here so black should try to
do something on the Keen side
yeah exactly
Romance languages are pretty similar
also Romanian is quite similar to
Spanish Romanian Italian French I think
don't think I'll come from Leiden
yeah yeah I took like four years of
Roman Empire Roman Empire f5 oh that's
that gives me the e for ask where are
you taking on g5 yeah I think I'll take
on g5 and then play 94 this looks circle
for white then 94 93 I'm controlling all
the light squares so 9 d3 first I don't
know why but he can't play a first
that's why I'm coming to eat for next
move and I don't know just play solid
here Quincy 222 even GE three to control
more squares so I only understand 3ds
3ds that's another language which is so
tough
I play actually in the Swedish Li a team
in London which is a nice City very
close to Denmark and this nice breach
that joints then Denmark and Sweden you
know any Swedish player old Fenderson
yeah Guinea or Chris yeah I'm the number
one now in Sweden oh wait you know him
yeah I do
don't used to be a Rastafari you know
yeah yeah yeah his hair
and I forgot his name it's needless
grande yeah yeah it's actually a really
nice guy he's I think he's plain now in
the Isle of Man grunts freeze you guys
can follow this tournament actually one
spot for the candidates in the grunts
freeze of defeating and relax invention
from from the feeding the Holly prize
for the candidates you can do that
through the isle of man me no no I just
mean here's someone that's a qualifying
tournament for the candidates yeah we'll
go to the candidates right away okay
so that's why it's so interesting what
if Carlos Italy yeah means counting on
Fabio playing so they cannot qualify of
course really so I think if Magnus wins
so the second will go also
now that ding bearing has qualified to
through the wall cap I think now there
is a spot for writing which the ridge
above didn't win the world yeah rajab oh
you mean but didn't qualified right so
because he was second oh and about the
two of them qualify for the candidates
so this means that now
onigiri has really great chances to
qualify for the candidates because ting
Leland is not going by raiding so the
next one going by writing is a GED I see
and then I'm going to play h4 Queen a 1
check King g2 and then I'm going to play
c5 and all my pieces are protected as
far as I can see you right you would
call this strategically winning right
yeah I mean I don't know if it's well
you're not because white is quite
actually sorry black is quite solid but
it's much easier to play in time trouble
for white here I don't know what you do
is actually not easy to improve my pcs
when I go see 666 he goes these six I
can now maneuver with my night because I
don't have to protect c5 anymore so
let's say b6 or b5 Wow
okay now is where I can maneuver with my
knight I don't know where but I will do
it 91 and then maybe not a three maybe
g4g five and position is actually quite
nice for white so nine a tree and then
g4g fives my idea wonder if you could
have played 95 there oh wow 95 for DC 5
DC 6 you see some baby baby okay then we
see for pretty pretty interesting takes
takes B 5 piece of d 8 can he go for it
yeah kara I'm just taking this guy I'm
just taking this guy B 5 go to DA play
passively and then I bring my kid come
on come on retreat your bishop is your
only chance
it's your only chance my friend 91 kina
3 yeah this is what I'm gonna do 91 kina
freaking Eve for if my cane reaches this
pot then it will be extremely happy g5
come on is dynamo I'm gonna go h5 after
key f5 just g4 Kingi 4 unless you said
strategically these looks yeah whoa come
on I don't believe that
so takes na na nanana these kind of work
were just king for exactly he's got to
resign soon again and I love that so 20
seconds for Dean cognitive France pain
actually you know that in Spain is the
country where we organized more
international chess tournaments in the
wall yeah so money told me to go I think
it's Madrid right like there's a lot of
Barcelona Barcelona so yeah you should
go to in summer if you want to play like
you can play actually eight tournaments
in a row
Bali for norms so that's why for example
a lot of people from Latin America they
they come to Spain to play the whole
summer from June to October there's
actually one tournament every week so
it's actually really nice he wanted you
improve your chest someone told me it
was cheap too oh well you were talking
about that earlier I'm a hot stream that
it's cheap yeah I mean depends of the
city yeah Barcelona Madrid are not so
cheap
but there are some other places were
cheaper yeah so d5 okay I'm gonna go
native three and Bishop before we reach
there Broncos in defense if he goes for
Bishop e7 we're in the Queens gambit and
normal position so I'm going to for
Bishop g5 Bishop f4 is more trendy these
days okay I'm going to go with III now
just solid chess let's see where he goes
b6 is a more of eight six full of by
ninety four is the last cut variation I
think goes for this a6
alright I'm gonna go Queen c2 and maybe
he wants to take and then play b5 that
sounds reasonable to me yeah exactly
suggests it's a very strong tournament
which takes place in in December so I
will actually be the commentator this
year over there in December you guys can
join us there compare with you so almost
everything is cheap in space
that's actually quite true I mean they
told me that New York is crazy
yeah I'm gonna spend like a lot of box
over there I'm gonna leave my friends
and then we are going out every day so
it's gonna be tough somebody told me
that in Denver Colorado like a bottle of
water can be nine dollars in Colorado in
Denver yeah really
I'm gonna take this guy here f6 and then
probably 94 was my idea I think I got
nothing out of the opening
I'm playing against Tom Williams so
actually devastated the most expensive
party in the u.s. sir I think I mean I
went to Miami I I went for dinner with a
friend and then we asked just a simple
pasta dish justa spaghetti carbonara one
the barrio of sangria and then one salad
it was like 200 bucks you know of course
we were in the main street and stuff
like that we wear the stupid ones yeah
oh now you can I have a little something
I don't know if you see five yeah c5 is
the only movie right otherwise make c1
oh that was really one and then not even
that there would be a lot of pressure
yeah but he spotted it so okay let's
just try to play d1 maybe c4 is even
interesting now for him so incredible
that the game that Magnus Carlsen won
today you saw that - did he pull it now
- Zubov Ukrainian player he was
completely losing and then he was a draw
and then he managed to to win that game
c4 okay hmm I think black spiders yeah I
think blacks better I'm gonna go a four
here I'm not so sure about this move me
there will be six maybe wanted to go 95
there maybe didn't you should play d5 is
that man yeah d5 takes rook takes Queen
c7 that's what I saw a good spy yeah
jisuk and then I didn't see anything
there so defied that the probability
file is that suddenly this Bishop on f6
is a terrible piece is a good kisser
what I mean
Queen d5 now that sounds good for him -
so easy - so if the position is not good
we have still the chance of flagging him
I'm an expert in that
hey why don't you play shell in shell in
challenge me yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna
play challenge shelling falling the next
game
he's actually feeling master really
strong player from Germany so I'm gonna
play you in the next game I'm probably
will be closing the stream right it's
some one and half hours okay so this
game and one more game and E for you fur
looks good that I think he plundered the
pond because this is 695 the poem mr.
William mr. William nice cat nice hat
looks like a boxer katia Mayweather I
would be afraid if I see this cat you
know in the streets or for sure asking
me for some money you know when they
want to steal this something in Spain
they ask you for money for gasoline you
know and then do you realize if somebody
asks you you have one zero for gasoline
for my motorbike then you know it's
going to screw you it's trying to steal
something from you this is the way they
start the conversation that happens here
too it's the same gas yeah okay now
we're completely waiting yeah so this
night don't c4 is from taxes fantastic
pace now we're going back to c1 with my
rook then bring the kid to the center
probably some d5 later on at least 90
signals waiting come on pepper it's
doing this punch guy do it okay get me
that second chance now I'm gonna take it
I see this happen a lot where a
grandmaster will play a lower rated
player and the lower rated player might
get a nice position but they don't
really know what to do with it yeah man
the GM just finds a way to win yeah
all right so let's go d4 against
shelling for yes beating me like he's
okay last game guys
he's actually is reading 8 to 13 is 5
points so it's time to build him back
okay
he's 6 9 of 3 it's going forward let's
play a Catalan here with g3 Bishop d2 is
really fast too so Queen c2 a6 main line
a 457 c5 ok I don't know about this move
ok just take this guy and then Queen C
for right Dustin that looks really
natural b6
okay how about b4 here b4 b4 looks good
looks good let's go you've got to go
back to East 7 or something like that
then my bishop on b2 will be pretty nice
in this diagonal also nice if I want to
go just Brooke a7 over there soon okay
let's go Bishop b2 maybe queen is 7
[Music]
okay we should be to queenie seven a
little bit annoying because this
disappointed me for is hanging so bp7
and then let's play 92 probably queen is
seven is a nice move here
96 already attack in my pawn on b4 so I
could have go b5 here it takes a takes
rook takes a 1b she takes a 195 I wanted
to go Queen h4 over there then Bishop e7
probably but then I got some Mac g5
ideas that could be dangerous in this
position let's see he goes for 95 and
then queen 8 for Bishop e7 dang 95
Bishop takes you to be staked 86 and
then White's winning so he has to do
something about this probably 86 could
be good in this position 95 all right
okay that was a good move man what
should I do here Queen eg4 or queen
takes at least of nothing so I'm gonna
go Queen g4 and then then see what
happens
so g6 looks perfectly fine for us
some Queen T 4 could be coming even and
it's not to jam also to e4 the other
Knight to e5 I like my position now it's
got one minute of 44 seconds you wanna
draw I don't want to draw our keep
playing but I don't know I don't know
how to do it man I don't know how to do
it okay 95 8 624 is that interesting is
that like Cindy five very interesting or
maybe that's just a blunder let's go 24
here
let's go Queen d4 I want to keep playing
probably I'll end up losing but who
cares yeah this is bound to blitz who
cares
before so it's got to go back to ease
and then it's got Bishop c5 that's an
annoying move so 94 bishop c 97 94
Bishop c5 takes takes Bishop c5 into
meat
very nice ain't gonna go would no no
damn my friend not turn gone back to
beat you
he's got to go back no he goes to be for
now and I kind of move man going to kind
of move I'm going to be three now 94
Queenie to one minute 20 one minute ten
so Knight takes Queen takes and then the
e6 pawn is hanging the bishop on a1 is
now not so good the f6 pawn is doing a
fantastic job over there so 93 Wow
gonna go Queen a2 so Knight takes me
three Queen takes me three and then the
pawn on e6 is still hanging so it's gone
I mean I got one minute on five seconds
then there could be a pin on the D file
as well shelling for shelling for I'm
gonna beat you this time
Shelley Shelley Shelley what's going on
shelling f2 is also under attack oh my
god I don't know what to play here after
Queen where Queen d7 maybe 51 he
protects that point still can't go rook
e1 or I can't maybe I can maybe I should
I can no I don't know man really life is
terrible
life is 21 Bishop a4 1991 but then f2 is
hanging - I don't know man I just go
eight word to see what he does Bishop
takes c4 come on man it was just a
terrible move this was just completely
rubbish teenage - but I'm just
blundering everything now nine of two is
good so I'm gonna take here and then try
to survive let's say 94 here takes takes
and then does just try to flag him they
just try to flag him no 96 and then if 4
is coming let's say f3 here to stop
before come on Pepe I play fast stupid
guy so Bishop c300 Bishop c3 here t4
maybe I don't know t4 can I go g4 kind
of goat book see one book t1 takes takes
takes takes look f1 here at the pawn on
g7 is hanging I'm gonna take that for me
Group D one III III is coming okay well
good it's just wrapped it's just dropped
this just guy there III it's gonna come
and then I'm gonna have to resign
Bishop h6 let's see Bishop t2 9595 okay
just wanted this night and then all the
chance is to flack him that's like
[Music]
there's no no salvation for this time
extremely so slow man so slow okay good
game shall report okay guys this was
nice evening with you guys and I hope
you guys learned something I'll probably
be back next week right for another
session so it's been a pleasure
Caleb I'm saying yeah so guys if your
drink don't drive this has been a
presentation of the st. Louis chess club
you